you can pull out pictures of John F
Kennedy and LBJ John F Kennedy looking
at LBJ okay so when you look at John F
Kennedy looking at LBJ there are many
instances where you know uh um you just
don't see a lot of trust in the way he
looks at them you don't see a lot of uh
um
where you know he's worried what's going
to happen here so it's kind of like the
case where he has to go get him as a VP
to help him because he had Texas and etc
etc and he had a lot of power and LBJ
was more driven to become a president
than JFK was JFK wasn't really supposed
to be the president out of the Kennedy
it was supposed to be Joseph the oldest
son John F Kennedy kind of like he's
Alaska that ends up becoming a president
so you look at LBJ a lot of ambition
there to become a president okay that's
one person you look at the other one mob
what uh you know John F Kennedy was
trying to do uh to the Mob making their
life a little bit tougher RFK his
brother so could have been the
conversation of the mob talking to each
other where you have this uh a potential
conversation with multiple mob bosses
talking to each other saying look are
you seeing what RFK is doing targeting
everybody after we help them out in
Chicago or Illinois yes we got to take
this guy out one of them our bosses says
if we take him out John F Kennedy is
going to spend the rest of his life
targeting us but if we take John F
Kennedy out RFK loses his power he won't
be able to do anything we start with
John F Kennedy first and then we go to
RFK we're done with and we don't have to
worry about them coming after us so okay
cool let's go that route and then you
know if you've seen Godfather 2 there's
a scene in Godfather too where in Lake
Tahoe they're trying to kill Michael
they come and shoot up Michael's house
with the glasses I don't know if you've
seen this one scene where it's getting
shot up and then right afterwards you
see them in a creek there are a couple
other guys come and shoot them and
they're dead and the shooters are you
know dead at this point nobody can find
that who paid them to come and try to
kill Michael if a mobster is trying to
kill somebody they hire somebody to kill
the person and then they hire somebody
to kill the killers who are going to
kill the person so you can sit here and
speculate and look at all this stuff to
see what the motive is who benefited the
most from John F Kennedy being
assassinated
um I don't know if you're aware of this
uh after the 26 volumes of the Warren
Commission were published which was in
November of 1964.
three months later
Johnson sent the first combat troops to
Vietnam
that's a line that Kennedy was never
going to cross and that's very clear to
any historian who studies this case and
I don't have to tell you
what a big amount of money was made on
dredging up things like Cameron Bay Bell
helicopters Huey Etc you're talking
about hundreds of millions of dollars
okay that were spent over there and so
this is why some people
consider uh
what Eisenhower referred to which I'm
sure you're aware of what he called the
military industrial complex we much
never let them encroach on our human
rights and Liberties all right so I
believe that that was at least part of
the reason
for see look this whole debate that
sprouted after JFK came out
they now have these these guys
Declassified so many records on this
issue of this whole issue about Vietnam
that I don't think is debatable anymore
JFK was never going to go into Vietnam
and he was getting out at the time of
his assassination I'm sure you're aware
of that that he the issued in order and
remember Patrick
there were no combat troops in Vietnam
only advisors at the time of JFK's death
there was not one combat troop in when
he was inaugurated there was not one
combat troop in the day was assassinated
LBJ changes all of that within a matter
of of weeks some say it's actually days
all right and there's that famous scene
in in JFK which I'm sure you're aware of
where he's talking to the Joint Chiefs
and he says
just get me reelected and I'll give you
your warn okay so I think that's one of
the very serious motives in the JFK
assassination
I'll just piggyback agree with that I
I'll piggyback uh as well and talk about
you mentioned RFK I mean you know it's
it's no secret you know that
um you know if I heard of Evelyn would
uh and she has was on a record on a
documentary talking about LBJ and the
discussion between Bobby Kennedy and and
JFK and and getting LBJ on the ticket to
put him on the ticket with him for VP
you know and what a heated conversation
and you talked about the lack of trust
you know and then that was clear from
the beginning
um but you know I think you know Jim
just you know is exactly right there was
there was tension for different goals of
the two people for sure between the two
you know JFK and and LBJ
um and you also Jim mentioned uh Curtis
LeMay you know the joint cheese you know
there's a very famous movie made about
it's called seven days in May uh you
know old black and white film about uh
you know Lech coup uh you know uh and
and we we think about the the level of
power struggle that that we're talking
about here and and of course you know as
I mentioned before both Bobby Kennedy
you know being so
um uh um uh insistent and working very
diligently to fight organized crime
organized crime was a dirty word back
then it was the allegedly non-existent
you know and there were a lot of people
that didn't like so my point is there
were several people I do think the the
the push to try to do Vietnam was a huge
thing there are a lot of people that
these other these civil rights issues uh
fighting organized crime there are a lot
of people that had a lot of different
motives so what all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks bright if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]